man a lot of [ __ ] happened in 2019 yeah
a lot of [ __ ] like oh man I saw this
meme the other day and it was like why
does a January to August and from August
to December feel like two years and one
mmm like I felt like I've been through
so much [ __ ] I moved got out of a
relationship a five-year relationship
lost weight
ten pounds you lost weight this year
right like you got engaged this year
yeah we you know made some pivotal moves
in our business we opened up another
business concept that we're gonna
probably talk about soon man a lot has
happened this year saying a lot
you left Jacob knows this you know we
started genius brain this year yep jeez
man hasn't even been a whole year yeah
dude it's been like March or some [ __ ]
yeah oh man dude I can't believe it's
already the end of the year yeah well
welcome to the podcast guys we were
talking about change this podcast topic
is already there for you guys man it's
about change and growth for the next
year man I know like when people talk
about the subject seems a little corny
but at the end every December it's the
time for me to reflect the most I
actually do this thing where I always go
back home in December and that's the
time where I really get to think about
what I want to accomplish next year even
if I don't accomplish it it's okay but I
think like reflecting on what you've
done in the year really helps you move
forward and this year has been a lot of
changes for us like I haven't done that
in the last three years oh really in the
in the so in the last three years of my
life it felt like one one year [ __ ]
because I've been in a time warp from
the moment that Brown died up until my
breakup that whole time has been a blur
and just one hamster wheel of just
spinning and really yeah cuz my life
just felt like I needed to I needed to
just grab everything and fix it mmm cuz
right about the time that Browns I too
you remember we were working like a
[ __ ] yeah we were burning out
without realizing it we were opening up
so many different projects and
businesses we were just going and going
and going and at that time I remember
talking to bar 2 and we had this long
conversation and I was just like man I
feel like no matter how hard I'm working
how many problems I'm fixing as soon as
I fix one problem 10 more show up mmm in
the business in my relationship and it
just feels like we just keep going and
no matter how much I'm working there's
nothing being finished yeah there's no
film being done there's no projects
being done I'm just filming and filming
and filming cranking out content and the
you know there's nothing that's being
quote/unquote accomplished yeah or
there's no feeling of like okay I
finished this project now we're moving
to the next one
yeah and so because of that I felt like
holy crap man my life is just full of
constant problems and then after the
breakup my mind started to clear up and
I'm like hold on wait a minute like let
me slow down and I found I finally had
time to think hmm
and it was the wildest thing man because
we talked about like okay this year
we're gonna do this and this year we're
gonna do this those three years felt
like one year before you know it I'm 35
years old and I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm
30 what happened yeah I was like what
the [ __ ] happened dude I was 31 and then
all of a sudden I'm 35 yeah and it's
like it's the wildest thing dude
it is crazy I kind of felt like that
when when I was you know trying to lose
the weight originally and then when I
lost that weight that whole year was me
catching up with time that I lost right
because everything felt like a blur cuz
you burned out for like a year you're
recovering for a year right yeah for a
year and then it was it was hard because
I think we're workaholics so yeah and I
wasn't working it was it felt so odd and
mind you when I say I wasn't working I
was still working yeah I just wasn't
working as much
right so I was doing JK news you were
still doing project they're still
working on sip branding we'll do that
actually took up a lot of my time during
that time and you still we're working on
drips and swirls how still working on
drip so I was still working
I just wasn't working like how I dropped
your channel
I dropped my channel yeah you weren't
shooting outside of all this stuff
exactly so I stopped auditioning and I
stopped working on my channel which took
a fat chunk of my time I still had to
keep up with the stuff that we were
still developing but that that's what I
mean by not working yeah so and there
was a it was it was something that I
really needed I got to really reflect
about things that were important to me
and then stuff that I wanted to keep
around and every year when it comes to
New Year's it's like okay well what's
what's really important what am I gonna
keep that I've learned from this year
what am I gonna throw away and I feel
like every time every year that we get
older I get to take this [ __ ] chunk
out of me that I didn't want anymore I
just go poop get the [ __ ] out of here
that's a good thing to do I should start
doing that too like so it's like spring
cleaning right and then you kind of cut
out the things that you're like this is
not necessary why am i working on this
yeah there's it happens a lot with
people like I'm like why did I develop
this relationship for the hardest thing
that I hated the here's the thing I
hated the most that year that I was also
taking a break - I was also acting and
that was the time for me to explore if I
really wanted to act or not and what I
found out was that yeah I still want to
act
I still enjoy acting I like TV what I
dislike about it is and we hear this
word a lot its politics but that [ __ ] is
so prevalent and if whether you get a
job whether you work how many how much
dick you have to [ __ ] suck in this
industry its unfuckin real can we just
create art without all this [ __ ]
it's impossible it's so it's so [ __ ]
hard too it's like that's why we try to
be rich though honestly the only reason
why I want to make a [ __ ] ton of money
if I could make art untainted and not
[ __ ] worry about this [ __ ] dude it
would feel great because I would go into
these meetings right and they would be
some some people that I wouldn't meet
they'd go okay so I met like 30 casting
directors right and they go and people
tell me you better remember every single
one of their names I'm like why why how
can I [ __ ] remember thirty of these
[ __ ] names
like they were cool we had a great
interaction but I've met like a
gajillion of these people they're like
well they might be giving you oppor to
but that's me sucking dick yeah like I
want when I live in the now I have we
had a great conversation you're not
gonna remember everybody but because
this person is somebody who's a
gatekeeper for my career now I have to
force this relationship it's like I
don't want to do that I want to come
into an audition show you what I have
and you booked it off based on that
rather than but that's the game man yeah
that's the part of the game I hate -
yeah but I mean it's a career so you got
to see it as a job interview yeah it's
politics man and and I mean that's why
you don't [ __ ] work a nine-to-five
job yeah you know some people can thrive
in that environment and most of us can
that's why we're doing this like I'm
useless in the workplace you know what I
mean like yeah
but also I'm dangerous in the workplace
because from the last three companies
that I worked at I try to take it over
yeah step aside [ __ ] from the
inside mmm
every single job I've I've got lazy
[ __ ] fired yeah I've I manipulated the
boss to get them fired to kick him out
to do it like I [ __ ] took over weak
bosses they had the title but I was
actually running the show like and I
would do that multiple times and I think
you would do it too it's an
entrepreneurial trait like people that
end up being CEOs or whatever like they
do so because you get sick and tired of
how [ __ ] is being ran and you don't
[ __ ] like it and you don't like your
co-workers cuz to me I want a tight team
I wanna I don't want to walk into a
situation where someone's stealing the
company money by being a lazy [ __ ] yeah
and also too for me I could see that
because even like something small where
people are like yo you can you like you
know how to edit videos you know how to
use after facts all this stuff like
don't don't other people do that for you
it's like yeah they can but the reason
why I've learned to do it myself
is because I don't want somebody that
give me [ __ ] and then for me to just
simply because I don't know how to work
this oh yeah oh well it's not gonna work
because of this isn't that and I'll be
like which I've had run into this
form where it would be like a video I
need edited and like you know this video
is gonna take like you know like two
weeks to edit and I look at that I'm
like no no it's not yeah I'm like I was
like if you don't know how to edit this
simple sketch which doesn't require much
color editing and all and it's really
just chopping and then using like my
plural eyes to sync up the sync up the
sound which you are going to use because
you because the long story short this
editor was like telling me that he goes
oh yeah it just takes time to sync up
the audio which is lazy it's like [ __ ]
there's something called PluralEyes like
you know about pluralizing you're
literally saying that because you want
to get the job done in two weeks and get
paid now oh yeah and you know like I'm
letting them know about the app I'm like
oh [ __ ] this guy knows what he's talking
about it's like yeah you trying to
[ __ ] take advantage of me and so this
is why I like to learn my things yeah
you got it though yeah most good
business owners know their business from
top to bottom yeah it's like you can't
you can't you can't pull the [ __ ] you
know what are the sheep's wool over my
eyes like yeah I know what's going on
yeah but it's pretty important to have a
dream you could take team you could
trust
don't you built that then you can trust
that they'll find people that can I wait
well - yeah it's it's it's super
important - because like even like when
I work with other companies and they
give me [ __ ] it's so easy to call
out and I and I [ __ ] hate it when
somebody who is in a higher position
they try to say some [ __ ] because they
think you don't know any better and it's
like well you got to be political David
you can't just cuz I'll call them out
when it's the right thing to do like I
mean you're great at mafia just put it
in the workplace I'll put it we'll put
it in put it in that space cuz for me
like when it comes to business that's a
game yeah so I don't take anything
personal man like like sometimes I have
fun [ __ ] with people because they're
[ __ ]
but I don't know like you know a lot of
it is like I feel untouchable too
because I don't work for anyone yeah and
you know you can go into a room
boardroom and talk some [ __ ] and do and
I have which I've done to some what and
one of my guilty pleasures is um [ __ ]
ignoring old men when in a boardroom
if they start bullshitting me if they
start Hollywood big [ __ ] me in the
middle of what they're saying I would
start talking to someone next to me they
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] yeah
you don't get they'll talk talk talk
talk talk and you don't give them
attention and you [ __ ] cut them off
and start talking to their buddy and
give them more attention they don't know
what to do and I love seeing their
[ __ ] look in that face you know like
you just disrespect I was talking here
Hey
hey and it's like I'm gonna ignore this
[ __ ] I don't care if you work with so
and so and so and so and so so in the
middle of that I will cut them off dude
and that's the thing is like that's my
pride talking cuz I enjoy doing it it's
like I'm getting horny watching them
doing that okay it's like I mean I
that's the biggest why we decided to
really invest in ourselves like even
like doing the food businesses that we
started it was like how can we keep
taking paychecks these small paychecks
to promote other people's businesses and
yeah we could promote our own business
and create something dope exactly and
it's a long-term thing something that we
care about because eventually there's
gonna be a day when we all stop doing
brand deals you know and that's when you
know that we either sold the company we
made millions of dollars or you know
they're doing so good that we don't need
to do brand deals yeah everything is a
balancing act yeah this podcast is
brought to you by a better men
betterment was built to help you make
sense of what to do with your money no
matter or your financial experience
while investing involves risk better
men's technology can help you grow the
money you have and set financial goals
for the future get started by
downloading the betterment app today
that's B e
tter m e m t for the betterment of you
now here's an honest question how are
you supposed to know what to do with
your money very few of us are exposed to
meaningful advice on how to manage our
finances even fewer had the means to get
professional financial guidance
betterment is a platform that was built
to do something radical to give
accessible financial advice that puts
you first if you're like most Americans
your money is probably sitting in a
savings account likely earning you next
to nothing maybe you have an investment
account that you're not really sure what
to do with betterment can help you make
sense of what to do with your money
investing involves risk but you don't
have to know the ins and outs that the
stock market to start saving more or
start investing for your future
betterments technology will put your
money to work
choosing the stocks and strategies that
are right for you because we know you
have other things to do
betterments platform can even provide
kindness on what financial goals make
sense for you give your money a new home
with betterment peace of mind included
download the betterment app today that's
be tter ME and tea for the betterment of
you so what are some of your goals for
next year
well I think I want to do do more things
that are rewarding to my soul these past
several years I'm going through this
part of my life where I've worked work
worked for things that I thought were
passions but in reality it was
opportunities so you know like you get
an opportunity to make six figures and
you can't read you can't turn that down
you know but now I will now it's not
about the money I'm pretty comfortable I
don't work for money anymore
what I do now work for is the service of
people and what I mean by that is like
specifically fans right so you know I
have my jemaldin Academy yeah because I
really believe that there's so many just
basic level life skill [ __ ] that's cool
and most people's parents should teach
them but what's mind-blowing to me is
not a lot of people know basic finance
basic credit card how the [ __ ] they
don't even know how credit cards work
just not only that like how to get a job
like people don't know how to get a job
in the field that they want how to make
a killer resume how to [ __ ] interview
and win like they don't know how to like
make side money and not just like
finance they don't have good social
skills there's so much life skill [ __ ]
that they don't know what to do and
that's really rewarding to me because
it's already been open like three months
yeah and a lot of people are going
through it and they're showing me the
results of what they went through and
not only that I'm digging through all of
my old messages and the other day I saw
this one girl she had a catering company
and she messaged me in 2015 and then I
saw recently she messaged me again in
2019 and I never responded back but in
the first message she was like hey I'm
kind of interested I want to build a
business I'm inspired by you guys
19 she's like oh [ __ ] I was going
through my messages don't know if you're
gonna read this but I actually ended up
opening up two restaurants
yeah and it's all thanks to you guys
your podcast your videos and to me I was
like this is what I want to do it's so
[ __ ] rewarding to me to see the people
that are watching us and then they build
their own [ __ ] and a lot of the people
that I work with - our fans yeah or I
wouldn't call them fans men they're my
friends but they and but they you know
they grew up either watching me or they
were inspired or whatever right and then
they they make a life for themselves
yeah we somehow find each other just by
mutual friends or whatever they're like
amen I watched your [ __ ] I used to watch
it all the time and we start talking we
hit it off before you know it we're
working on something together or
something you know whatever and yeah
like one of my partners for jemaldin
Academy you know we met at a karate camp
and Alex is helping me out building the
whole entire business and so I think
this is my next phase in life which is
like yes I have my JK yes I have my
writing I films I have all this stuff
but it's really true now I know why Bill
Gates or like when people get ball in
the next stage in their life what they
want to do is help other people you know
cuz that kind of [ __ ] it's it's a
different kind of feeling I mean you
know when you go do [ __ ]
meet-and-greets and all that right and
you meet the fans and then they tell you
their story of what they went through
based off of your videos it's like [ __ ]
that really happened all I was doing was
shooting the [ __ ] with my buddies yeah
but it clicked and they felt something
and you changed the life and that to me
is just so [ __ ] dope so I think 2020
is gonna be all about that for me I mean
that's literally the only reason why I
still do YouTube like other than that
there's no other reason oh yeah because
algorithm the [ __ ] bro we're not making
nothing yeah I like on a previous
podcast like I mentioned the live show I
don't know if it's previous depends on
when it goes up but I'll mention it
again this channel makes jack [ __ ] like
people think I'm saying that just to say
it like this channel doesn't make
anything dude I don't have kids
the content it's not it's not made for
me any people even with people who do
have kid-friendly content they're
getting the [ __ ] now they're getting
[ __ ] now everybody's getting [ __ ]
dude the only people that are making
money is Google that's it yeah David
door door [ __ ] did uh I read that
article where he was making $200,000 a
month and now he gets more views but he
made like $2,000 a month or some insane
amount yeah I'm like how is that even
possible
I make that much yeah I went from making
$15,000 a month on my channel to just a
thousand or two yeah
and that's true all across the board
thank God for patreon because it helped
JK news survive yeah like those look
like you have to realize the the extent
of what happened to the the revenue
source to the point where I well you
know first of all number one thank you
[ __ ] patreon people because without
you guys I wouldn't be posting on this
YouTube guys I make I would make my
money in doing what I'm doing right now
but I wouldn't have to post I I post I
do the podcast because number one I
really really enjoy it
number two I also create these random
videos where I do my old-fashioned
videos I mean gets like what eighty
thousand views which is like literally a
third what it used to get but I do it
because it for some reason it making
people laugh and making them feel good
it's addictive you know what I mean yeah
and I don't realize like the things that
I do until I meet somebody in person
they go I was in a really dark place
that you made me laugh and that really
helped me out and yeah oh [ __ ] that was
the biggest reason why I went into
comedy like I did comedy because I think
that when I was going through really bad
things the only thing I could do was
laugh about [ __ ] and that made me feel
better and so I wanted to do the same
for other people when I was doing
stand-up and I found out that even if I
don't do stand-up I can do it in film
yeah I could do it in YouTube videos and
now I have this podcast which honestly
genius brain was supposed to be a
straight comedy podcast but I found out
that people gain more from it from
having the jokes but still talking about
stuff that they could walk away and
learn from
yeah and it's more naturally us like
these conversations that we have this is
really just what we do all [ __ ] day
like even in between the breaks we'll
shoot the [ __ ] for another hour yeah but
like I was you recorded that [ __ ] like
right and it will go to will go to
dinner and then we'll talk again like
this is our friendship yeah and yeah and
I think when it comes down to it we vibe
alot because we're more like about the
community in a practical sense of art or
creation right that's why I think we
don't really we're not in the for like
whole fame chasin thing like it's like
take it or leave it this is this is who
we are [ __ ] it like if you like this you
like us if you don't that's fine I'm not
gonna chase clout but if we build a
following being able to be as true as
possible I think that's the best reward
because there are you know we know
people who don't want to be who they are
anymore
yeah and it's killing them cuz they want
to change the persona and all that
they're afraid to do so and I'm like you
should have been you should have been
real from the start well maybe they were
real but that was so [ __ ] long ago
that it was a different human being back
then it's it's so odd when I see that to
where I think when when I so when we
first started out and going you know
doing these like YouTube shows right
where we will get booked for these
venues which still happens to this day
and I just don't do it as much as I used
to um you know because it was exciting
for me back and I would take anything
and everything yeah to be a stand-up
comic but now it's just like ah I'll do
it if I if I feel like I want to but I
remember I think the consensus is every
time I meet somebody they say the same
thing they go wow you're exactly how you
are in your videos I'm like I hear the
same [ __ ] I'm like yeah what were you
[ __ ] expecting and they're like and
they tell me stories about other
youtubers that they mean you know and
they're like yeah I'm really like them
that much they're just so different like
they're very standoffish they're very
socially awkward and I'm like well
that's because like when you're on when
you're in in a room and you're just
talking to a camera and you're only
dealing with the people you have to deal
with it's easy it's very easy that's
harder for me to go just talk to a
camera because I'm used to talking in
groups or people some people but people
who are socially awkward I mean I always
say that's the best way there's a reason
why some of these people before us like
they only could talk to a cameras
because they couldn't talk to human
beings and that's the hard part for a
lot of people right that's why I like
Jake Kane he was such an easy transition
for me because I'd been doing stand-up
since day one it's like oh I could I
could talk to
[ __ ] days like doing this [ __ ] and
that's how we got started as a group as
friends yeah like not solo artists I
mean not to even knock their style it's
different but that is not gonna perform
on stage well yeah if you're not a
people person or if you can't even
perform like you can't you can't
interact with humans obviously maybe
they are cool as people but it's not
gonna transfer in real life charisma is
not gonna transfer because they're
scared it's you can't be scared you
gotta just be chill they always say
never meet your idols man you get
crushed yeah sometimes too like I get
scared to meet my idols if ur like Dave
Chappelle if I meet Dave Chappelle I'm
just gonna [ __ ] try to you know he
could do no wrong in my eyes okay spit
in my mouth yeah I thought you loved
that guy man but yeah when I went to a
couple of college shows and they were
mentioning uh I always like to ask them
they go okay so who are the youtubers
that you met that you didn't like and I
and it's so funny it is always the same
people - yeah it's always the same
[ __ ] people I'm like what the [ __ ]
are these guys doing every time mmm they
pissed off the world yeah like how could
you what are you doing these people that
brought you out here and they're paying
you like what are you doing and they
said like - no it's just that they're
what happens - with some people
especially when you get Fame at at such
a young age I think that that Fame gets
their head and they don't know how to
act I know it's funny - it's not even
actual Fame if you think about it yeah
it's very small you got like 10,000
people that's a [ __ ] village homey
yeah or whatever right
there's even if you got a million like
it don't matter like you're not that
special
you're not that [ __ ] big shut the
[ __ ] up but there's a lot of that
happening in the funniest thing to me is
when they try to big dick and they don't
know who the [ __ ] I am yeah and they're
smaller than me and they're trying to
like talk cause you know they're [ __ ]
about like what they've been through who
they're with like if you go to these
networking of the outs or whatever and
then you're like oh cool yeah and it's
like what do you do I just [ __ ] around
on YouTube and yeah like oh yeah how
many subscribers you have 1.7 million
yeah or you go like my Instagram yeah I
got Instagram yeah you know yo I went to
this influencer event and I only went
because they were giving me free [ __ ]
and then I took Mariel there and there
was a couple of girls who were there and
they were just walking around like they
were this [ __ ] [ __ ] dude you know
what somebody walks around and you can
look at their aura and their presence
yeah it just basically says I'm better
than you and it was like these young
girls and they were just kind of
strutting around like the 30,000
followers yeah even less us is what I
found out so do you you basically walk
around and then you have an attendant
next to you that has a placard or like a
card of your name yeah just so the
brand's know that a give these people
stuff for free and then you can take
pictures with them and post them and say
that they stop by your booth right which
is already weird for me but there's this
dude that was walking around here my
sign up look at the mother April put the
sign down relax man my [ __ ] you don't
you don't got to do all that [ __ ] yeah
like they told my half deal it's like
don't [ __ ] to worry about just chill
I was like honestly I'm just gonna walk
around looks and stuff and if I need to
get you just let me know just go on
chill but there's a little girl and I
say little she was not little she was
like a full grown ass adult but she had
her placard around and she's just
walking around like it was just
literally talking to that attendant
person like she owned them like well I
was like her Butler and I was like you
know what the [ __ ] is this and I just
kind of like okay cool Grayson Mountain
you want to study that uh-huh and then I
looked up her name right and who is this
person
she's like this regular girl who just
posted pictures of her socially at like
15,000 followers I'm like wow that
little amount of power went to your
[ __ ] head where you truly believe
that you were above this other human
being there's a lot of people with small
followings that are notorious for
wanting freebies they get they get mad
if you don't give it to them yeah if you
don't give it like I could give you free
promotion and pull my nuts [ __ ] how
about that
cuz me I only do free [ __ ] if I love the
brand no and like if it's convenient
yeah like shoutouts to the Sheraton and
[ __ ] Vietnam and they took care of me
I did they didn't pay me though but I
got a penthouse suite and I stayed there
the whole time for free that's [ __ ]
tight yeah I mean if you think about it
um
that's like a thousand dollar value or
whatever but still like I get paid more
on my brand deals right
I get I get way more money but in my
opinion I felt like I was really happy
to work with them and I'm all like I'll
go farm beyond man I'll [ __ ] do a lot
and I liked working with their team so
sometimes it's not about the money to
like for me at my level like I'm not
even saying like it's a bigger level but
the the the levels are different what
you ask for
right if you're at a lower level so
don't get this twisted when people value
themselves at an amateur level on the
views on the on the numbers they're
they're valuing their self as a human
being when I say these numbers I'm
saying it as a business and a brand so
don't get it twisted there's different
levels to that right cuz you got your
Walmart and you got your like everyday
corner shop whatever liquor store or
whatever so I'm looking at this as a
business so it doesn't make someone
better or worse I'm just saying the
business might be bigger or smaller yeah
so if you're at a bigger level like Kim
Kardashian or whatever like you're
getting hundreds of thousands of dollars
just to mention something or take a
picture or whatever I'm not at that
level but if you're at the lowest level
you're probably not gonna get paid yeah
if you only got thirty thousand
followers or twenty thousand you'll
probably get paid a couple hundred
dollars to post something if you're
lucky if the brand likes you if they
think that your persona matches their
style they like the way you take
pictures maybe like the quality they'll
[ __ ] with you but in most cases they're
gonna give you free product and at that
level you want to look the part
because your brand building right so you
want to take the product you want to
take the pictures you want to and into
at that level to free [ __ ] like you're
still probably working a nine-to-five
job or you have a side hustle or you're
whatever right so you're thankful for
free [ __ ] not that you won't be at a
higher level but you know you're still
making money
hourly probably yeah so when you get a
free makeup kit or whatever you're like
woohoo right once you get to a certain
level like in the middle tier from the
hundreds of
to the millions you don't give a [ __ ]
about free product anymore mm-hmm
because brands are throwing free product
at you left and right
yeah and not only are they throwing free
product they're paying you thousands and
thousands of dollars yeah to talk about
the product to [ __ ] sell it to
[ __ ] spawns you know you're all that
so when you're at that level right you
don't really you go to these [ __ ]
networking events you get all you like
people are constantly giving you free
[ __ ] I don't even want to hold a gift
bag yeah cuz and that's not even it
sound like you know ungrateful I'm just
saying like there comes a point when you
go this is just too much free [ __ ] and
I'll take it because I'll do giveaways
and I'll give it to my fans right but I
don't need this [ __ ] and it doesn't have
the same effect as when you had 20,000
followers or at the at that level where
you're just like yeah I was gonna buy
this anyway I need to save it right me
I'm a cheap bastard for so if it's like
vitamins or if it's things that I need
I'll [ __ ] take it but for the most
part they're things that are like you
know you don't really need I don't know
that's why I don't do a peel boxes right
I did a peel box thing for a little bit
and it keeps sending you random [ __ ]
yeah yeah number one I appreciate that
you're sending me stuff to show your
appreciation but I don't need you to
give me stuff to show me appreciation
like I'll show you appreciation when I
see when you come up to me approach me
in a normal way and I said hi to you
when I give you a hug that's how I'll do
my appreciation you don't need to show
me appreciation by giving me [ __ ] you
mean like fan mail yeah like you don't
like reading along as letters about life
it got it got a little too much you know
as a lot and then I received these
family and I can't throw it away
because they took the time to [ __ ]
handwrite this thing so I actually have
a box in my house full of just fan mail
and I really used to throw away I throw
away after I read it I can't do it I
literally can't do it so I have a box in
my storage where I haven't thrown away
this fan mail this podcast is brought to
you by a fiver my friends if you have
not used Fiverr before you are missing
out let's talk about finding freelance
talent for your business or project
finding the right freelancer can be
time-consuming frustrating and expensive
trust me
I know where do you go find the talent
how much will it cost and how can you be
certain they'll deliver thanks to Fiverr
finding the right freelancer doesn't
have to be a strug goal my friends I've
used fire for a lot of things
specifically you guys know I do music
and when it comes to album art that I
need to get done in a jiffy I have used
fiber with a lot of people who do
graphic design and a lot of different
artworks to do my art for my music and
five of my friends makes it easy super
easy communication got things done on
time with on the right deadlines and the
people that I do work with they have
great reviews on Fiverr so if you guys
need to get stuff done and you need it
done for an affordable price or you can
find an affordable price for the stuff
that you need get it on Fiverr my
friends so check it out take five and
check out fiverr.com and you will
receive 10% off your first order by
using my code brain it's so easy don't
waste any more time and get the service
you deserve
by going to F I ve are our comm code
brain fiber it starts here and it's just
it's because I'm not a very
materialistic person so that type of
stuff doesn't really like let's say you
said like for example if you if you meet
me up like no more like cats sweets when
she gives me cupcakes I love that [ __ ]
because I'm gonna make goods that makes
sense because I could eat it it'll
disappear it's not taking up space so
you shouldn't get baked sweets from
strangers so you know they love being
fans yeah I got I mean I sometimes one
time somebody gave me the sprinkle
cupcake and I just sat there staring at
it like I should I eat this [ __ ] because
I was like trapeze and me yeah I don't
know I don't know I think we have loving
fans but you just never know
you never there's a lot of crazies out
like you know like I've uh that like
food stuff it just doesn't disappear
somebody once brought me a McChicken
filet-o-fish and some chicken nuggets
this muhfucka I knew my heart dude I was
always gonna came with a bag of
McDonald's he was I'll take poisoning
for that [ __ ] he was like I know you
like this [ __ ] I was like Dawg I will
suck your dick right now just cuz you
you saw my soul dude I was hungry too
after the show and he knew what's up
that's a good fan dude am but yeah I
mean if I ever meet you you give me like
a
a letter or note I'm definitely not
gonna throw it away I've never have so
give that to me I'll read it but if
terms of like I like when I had the peel
box people sent me boxes of [ __ ] and I'm
like yo I can't keep this yeah same here
like I have mountains of things that
sent me a letter [ __ ] I'm probably gonna
do a giveaway for and I feel bad like
when fans give me [ __ ] like free stuff
and maybe the snacks and stuff will eat
it will keep it Axl yeah yeah cuz that's
kind of unique to like we get snacks
from Canada Hawaii like all over the
world and that's always cool so we'll
have that at the office but for the most
part man like you know you get to a
certain point as a influencer or
whatever you're a walking advertisement
for a lot of businesses and it just give
you so much stuff and so you kind of
tell who the amateurs are the new people
in the world like of this is cuz like
they're out there grabbing everything
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that because if I like the product
I'll grab a few things - yeah but the
way they go at it is like a it's like a
Chinese person at a buffet and there's
[ __ ] snow crab legs coming out listen
if you want to send me an iPad or you
want to sell make it a computer or
something I'll take that [ __ ] I'll take
it cuz I can make use of it
yeah you know but you know I like I
somebody wants to send me a toaster I
was like [ __ ] I'm gonna do this right
it's like oh is the custom toaster with
your name on it I was like thank you I
appreciate this but what am I gonna do
with this I have a toaster you know I
don't know it's very sweet though the
thought of it's very sweet and I really
really do appreciate it but it's like
man don't even do all that if you want
to do something yeah but by my know if I
bring out merch which we should bring
out some [ __ ] that's a 2020 goal for
me actually no no unloading things in my
house oh it dude my place dude I got rid
of so much [ __ ] it feels great like I
want to get into fashion so well
clothing clothing is different right
like I love clothing right like I've
just had to throw away a lot of [ __ ]
because I kept losing weight but like
clothing is [ __ ] dope like I don't
think when I mean by materialistic
things and what I like I just want to
clarify this it's what what is the
intrinsic value that
talk to your life right oh yeah like I'm
not gonna use it then collecting it
exactly if you love fashion and you love
shoes and that's something that brings
you joy and it's a hobby of yours then
yeah I could join put you yeah if sparks
joy right [ __ ] Marie Kondo do shout
out to the lady man let's [ __ ] sometimes
oh [ __ ] yeah
Marie Kondo yeah Doug let me tell you
something that lady did you you spark
some join me dude let me tell you
something lady I love her shout outs to
you did you look like you make a squeaky
voice when you have sex Marie Kondo like
that's what she means by sparks stories
like what does it do for you right yeah
and if it's fashion and clothing that's
not you being materialistic in my
opinion it's you putting money into
stuff that makes you happy and you're
doing it in a reasonable amount yeah for
me if I wear clothes justice just to
have this dope [ __ ] and be like oh I got
dope [ __ ] then that's me being
materialistic but if you like clothing
and you like the way it makes you look
and you love like putting clothes
together then it makes more sense like
my biggest thing was like people who buy
shoes just to be like yo I got this shoe
you're a [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] dude you
look so stupid it's the dumbest thing
ever it's like you have shoes just to
show other people that you got this
[ __ ] shoe it's the most pitiful thing
I've ever seen in my life and I say that
because that was me
so it's like materialism to you is
someone who buys [ __ ] for others like if
to impress others to keep up with the
Jones and like they don't necessarily
want it or maybe they do but it's to
impress people not because they care
about it yeah and so in your definition
of materialistic it's okay to like like
nice things
oh for sure a hundred percent I some
people believe materialism is also like
I think they consumerism and materialism
gets kind of mixed into where like
buying any luxury [ __ ] or any
unnecessary good is materialism
that's that definition too and there's
this whole minimalist movement that's
going on oh man those [ __ ] are
crazy dude that's crazy yeah and well
I'm gonna start unloading things because
you know I'm gonna be moving around a
lot probably gonna travel a lot 20 20
I'm gonna travel a [ __ ] ton mm-hmm a lot
like I'm gonna be going to you know I'm
probably
Europe as this [ __ ] thing is going
out right now as we speak but I'm not
gonna use a lot of the stuff in my house
I'm probably gonna give it to fans or
whatever you know yeah like I was
addicted to buying [ __ ] camera
equipment I was a shooting [ __ ] I don't
know why I think cuz I got so used to
buying that stuff yeah it was a good tax
write-off like I kept buying stuff but
then after a certain point I'm like you
don't shoot [ __ ] everybody who shoots
your stuff had their own stuff yeah why
do you why do you keep buying [ __ ] so I
stopped that stuff and I thought like
over like a hundred and fifty grand
worth of gear and it's like oh my god
what the [ __ ] if I wanted to open up my
own photography studio like an or video
I could I could right now but now it's
just like I actually you know the last
year or the ex was this year I got rid
of a lot of that equipment I sold a lot
on top of that I sold a lot of my shoes
I only have I'm I say only but it's like
maybe like I say like 20 pairs of shoes
left but that's because those shoes are
kind of a sentimental value in terms of
shoes that I wanted when I was a kid
growing up and also she was a that guy's
a gift yeah so I haven't been able to
get rid of it but other than that man
like yeah my version of materialism is
like the purpose and why you buy it and
what it does for you like how long's
that joy last yeah um if like I'll go
back to fashion if like people when they
are into fashion and they like the way
that they look that happiness lasts a
long time they'll go back to the outfit
again they wear that outfit again
they're like the way that dress looks
makes them look you like the way that
jacket makes them yeah fashions are
interesting because it's an art it's an
artistic expression yes but it's also
can be vain and it can be kind of
there's a dark side to it
that's as expensive as [ __ ] yeah same
with like working out though you know
like being too body obsessed and there's
a health aspect to it but there's also
like the extreme side of like body
dysmorphia and [ __ ] like that yeah and I
think anything can be [ __ ] up you know
let me tell you something clothing is
the most interesting thing to like for a
guy if you guys want to know something
for you dudes out there that they kind
of want to up level up your the way that
you look this is coming from me from a
guy who looks like he just I don't know
lives in a out of a cardboard box
I love how like we're into fashion too
but we don't consistently keep up with
it and we don't have any shame to be on
camera in our pajamas at the same time
yeah [ __ ] you guys I'm not worried
socks again but like with one of the
things that you guys can do as a guy
straight up is number one get a nice
[ __ ] haircut it'll be the biggest
help ever man when you there are some
dudes out there that I see with the
shittiest [ __ ] haircuts and you
wonder why people like women won't
approach you there's a few things that
girls recognize number one is your shoes
like clean kicks and then jeans if you
have shitty looking jeans and bad kicks
that's not what is a shitty Jean like
just to fit then the cut oh like if you
have to understand like your body type
like what how do you how does your legs
look like what's the fit in the cut that
makes you look the best jeans you could
wear a good pair of [ __ ] raw denim
raw denim jeans if you don't have raw
denim jeans or whatever that you want to
wear and some just some regular clean
kicks like let's just say we put on some
just some old school vans on you and
some dope jeans and a regular white
t-shirt you look you're not fancy but
it'll look decent enough where it looks
a lot better than a lot of the other
stuff they were exactly so like those
are like the basis up and get a clean
haircut like a haircut for a dude it's
like night and day for a guy when a guy
has like a [ __ ] up fade and then you
kind of let it grow out and then you get
your haircut you look like a different
person
yeah that's true a completely different
person I think like fashion does that
for a lot of people even when I when I
lost a whole bunch of weight like
getting back like 12 pounds recently
because of all the food shows but you
know when I lost a whole bunch of weight
and then you know I started wearing
clothes again
someone used some and it was it was
interesting like the reaction that you
get like and just having um thank you
just being be just being fit to like
it'll help with the fashion oh for sure
like clothes fit better yeah and you
just feel better and you can you have
more options fashion is hard to it's
like how do you take especially for guys
I feel like it's hard to like how do you
go beyond a flannel t-shirt jeans and
shoes you know like what's that next
level fashion stuff that kind of really
shows that you know how to put put
together pieces and colors and that's
the hard part you know like I think
there's that's that creative artistic
part about yeah that that's not easy for
people it's not easy for me to I have to
sit there and think about color palettes
like what what what rocks with what I
want to explore a lot but my cheap side
takes over and goes best to his
spaceship
that's why girls thrift do they thrift
mmm
so they take these stuff and they kind
of like alter it in the mix and dope and
I like thrifting the idea of it just
because you can make it look good
without caring about the name-brand and
what it does for you you know what got
me into actual like outfits and wearing
[ __ ] though video games GTA saints for
Lily yeah you could just sit there and
customize your character yeah I got into
dressing girls too
I used to just undress them but now I'm
just like my character [ __ ] yeah so I
enjoy it man I just wish I'm stuck in a
more I don't know I do buy [ __ ] when I
want to buy [ __ ] but I'm more practical
I think we're all the same like me and
bar like we like this stuff but then
we'll we're just too [ __ ] lazy to put
up with it cool clothing is [ __ ] lazy
man it's it's hard yeah it's hard yeah
like having to put people don't
understand why some of the most
successful and rich people on earth
don't give a [ __ ] about what they look
like because it's a waste of brain
energy for them it's a big yeah I have
to wake up and think about what makes me
look good [ __ ] that I got to do what aim
with food when you got to think of what
to eat it kills so much time you just
eat the same [ __ ] every day
yeah we're we're I mean and then you
could you have so many hours to just
like work on your [ __ ] yeah you know
like even today like so the recently I
just made like shoyu ramen right and the
the how [ __ ] grueling it was to make
this [ __ ] ramen dude just to have
this one dish took up way too much of my
time like it's not a very smart way of
using my time you know like first of all
let me talk about how I made this [ __ ] -
like I fished to get fish to create the
dashi stock unit straight from the
source
I went straight from the source I caught
the fish you brought the fish home you
cut the fish by hand I might as well
just grab the [ __ ] seaweed off the
water and use that you know I mean but
he grabbed the sea we dry it chop it up
yeah you know and the broth was like a
couple of like two-three hours and it
took to make the fish broth and then it
took me to three hours to make the the
chicken broth because I didn't have a
second pot so I had to make them at two
separate times
then I had to do the soy sauce marinade
for the chashu belly then I had to
marinate the eggs then I had to make a
flavored fat for the for the ramen broth
which also took time it was like [ __ ]
man I was like a two three day process
mmm when I couldn't just went to a
[ __ ] place in it about it you know
that's true I will say this though like
a lot of people don't focus on show you
or like shio ramen so when we talk about
ramen there's two different types right
there's there's chintan and Python
Python is what everybody likes it's that
tonkotsu broth big thick fatty
gelatinous and that's the one that
people are really gearing towards I
personally like I love Python ramen but
I like chicken ramen a lot too which is
that super clear bra yeah and so people
don't really care about this she'll
broth because they think it's too simple
but there's a way to make it seem simple
with a lot of body and a lot of flavor
so like that's the what I've been
focusing on also to when you make Python
ramen it stinks up the whole [ __ ]
house it's gonna smell like pork yeah
all the steam just gets on the walls and
all that it's gonna smell like like pork
guts and blood and I just don't know I
just hate that smell of sticks around so
yeah I've been doing like seafood broths
so I did the dashi with the with with
just the regular fish with so I caught
grouper whitefish and rockfish and I
took those carcasses or carcass and I
did that with like home Bouin and with
katsu bushi flakes and then some dried
sardines and i dashi broth with it but
just that whole process took such a
[ __ ] long time man and I and you know
the thing about what I love about ramen
too by the way and we talked about food
and authenticity recently ramen has no
[ __ ] about what what a classic ramen
should be maybe like with stuff like
noodles right yeah it's the rock star of
Japanese food man you could do whatever
you want there's no Orthodox method
everything is a you can do it you know
the way you want to do it yeah I add
something like like the one of the
ingredients that I used on my ramen is
something very different like I
caramelize these onions in a very
different way and that's actually one of
the toppings that I use for my for my
show you ramen it's like a French onion
kind of kind of like kind of like that
and like I just I just said [ __ ] it
let's get creative with this [ __ ] like
what do i it's like what do I miss in
this ramen that I wished
I had in my mind I was thinking I want
like an extra salty or sweet bite I was
like well I'm gonna caramelize these
onions and I caramelized it with um with
katsu a bushy flakes that I grinded up
some dashi powder and like own dashi
some some white pepper black pepper and
then mr. brown sugar and some molasses
and then I used that as like when you
bring up that that ramen you get a
little bit of those like burnt charred
sweet onions and you you slurp that [ __ ]
up it sounds good yeah oh that sounds
really good yeah that's like my version
of shoyu ramen and you when you retire I
feel like you're gonna open up a
restaurant I really do want to though
like that's gonna be your [ __ ] you're
gonna be super like old man about it
like you're gonna be like I feel like
opening today yeah and I'm gonna make
whatever I want to make I would love to
do like these private dinners for ya
I'll come in and they eat my that the
food that I make I'm not saying that I'm
a great chef but I think that I there's
a lot of food that I don't like and I
think that I have a good palate for food
because I I truly truly truly love food
if you had a team right and let's say
like we all lived in a in a cul-de-sac
or like a village but we had like a main
house that we all kind of get together
and eat at mm-hmm if you could be the
main cook but if you had a team that
would cook and clean and help you out
like if you got those ten fishes right
hmm and you [ __ ] made that [ __ ] would
you be down to like cook that [ __ ] every
day
yeah man cook if I had a team to do
everything I'd be dope like even even
when I was making this ramen I was like
damn I would love to do something so
against the grain of like typical ramen
shops that they have out here where it's
just always like that tonkotsu broth
yeah where mine is just only chintan
ramens it's only she'll and shoyu ramen
but and it's different variations of it
and like if people ask for that tonkotsu
broth they're like no we don't have that
here and I want I want to heighten their
like what kind of ramen [ __ ] places
is you know the funny thing is you're
talking about change only because the
foam coats of broth is what got popular
in this state yeah but that's actually a
new-school thing in Japan that's so
crazy
um what's not new it
just a new work craze like the og craze
is just show you Sheol and miso ramen
yeah that's what everyone that's what I
grew up on pork broth is a is a read I
forgot what area but the reason why they
use pork is because there's a lot of pig
farms there so that it might be like
Hakata style or whatever but they that
area is known to use like their pork
bone and things cuz that's just what
they have yeah
so that spread like wildfire because it
was like the new [ __ ] in Japan at the
time I don't know if this was like the
80s or whatever what everyone started
[ __ ] eating that [ __ ] like crazy and
then it came to the States and I hear
everyone that likes fattier and saltier
foods like I think Japanese food might
be a little too bland from the American
taste buds so everything that's more I
guess fattier does really well here yeah
like katsu and all that right and then
uh when you think about all the RET like
when you think ramen in America you
think tonkotsu broth you don't think
show you but in Japan like show you or
Co are the two staples yeah yeah I love
I think show you Robin is my favorite
that's my - yeah hands down it's like
because I made a sow with essentially -
the flavoring is this is like you have a
broth and you have so you have your your
stock in yogurt on it your Tata is your
flavoring right and so that your patent
would be either show you base or she'll
break it could be miso base or whatever
depending on the type of you ramen so
that you had chin down or Python so
that's why when I when I see people make
recipes I don't even think they
understand that they go oh this is the
miso ramen
oh my you don't make it with the broth
though yeah exactly separate yeah they
have the yeah so when they say miso
ramen it could be a miso ramen but it
could be chin con or pipe and then they
put that in there and then they put the
stock and then they mix it in exactly so
like I have I've grown to really love
shoyu ramen I like clean like she'll
ramen it tastes really great too but
then the show.you ramen has like this
extra level of like umami this
the flavor that I really like past a
shield yeah she'll is very basic it's
delicious but that surely Robin has that
shield base but it has an extra like
that that fermented soy sauce and then
gives it that extra buff that I [ __ ]
love and so like I've been working on
this like shoyu ramen recipe but it's
gonna change every time because when you
home cook you're not gonna use the exact
measurements every time I'm not going to
anyways that's why when you cook you
gotta have a guy just writing notes for
you man yeah
what did you put in there all right you
put that I put that's a genius thing to
do like if there was a guy like
following like a like a person that's
just always inventing [ __ ] just like all
right what you got all right yeah
because I wrote down the ingredients and
the and the stuff but as I wrote it down
and I tried it it wasn't good enough and
I made an adjustment and I forgot to
write the adjustment so because I'm
tasting as I'm going right so I'm also
making adjustments there's like like do
I really need this ingredient like
typically use this what if I took it out
do I need this because I think a lot of
times when people make stuff people add
more ingredients because they want to
say that they did something new to it
and I mean I meant a lot about these
recipes like they they go okay well I
put a crayon in - yeah it has this this
and that and I'm like well I don't taste
it so what was the point of putting that
in and I think it's just because I wanna
have a secret recipe like this is the
hitter but it's really not it just got
oiled into it yeah there's there's no
flavor of it at all whatsoever
so and maybe it's just I don't know
maybe my taste buds are dull I can't
tell the difference but I'll make it
like 2 or 3 ways I'm like that didn't
make sense so like why do they put that
in there oh so that's how you experiment
yeah you see if that ingredient actually
had an effect or not yeah and I also
like to make things that I I truly want
to make it better so it's like not
better in the sense of mine's better
than yours but to what my palate and
flavor what I like out of my food all
right yeah so you I mean how whenever
you ever seen caramelized onions in ER
Amin right I mean this somebody might
have done it before right I'm pretty
sure people have but I just thought in
with my flavor palate I'm like this
would taste so good with this show yeah
and so I decided to do it because that's
the same type of caramelized onions that
I have for my in-n-out burger recipe do
you think that ramen culture in America
is gonna evolve because I think so I
think it's just the beginning I
is that the cusp like I think it's it
really is the the problem that I see
with ramen culture here is that they're
not people don't take the craft as
serious as Japanese people do and the
way that I see that a lot of Japanese
people when they create their food it's
their life like this is what I will do
to the day that I [ __ ] die well the
spots like tots annoy are the ones that
are doing well like we're calling or
whatever they're all the wrong hand yeah
and I think that's the difference I
think that's what's gonna change the
standard taste palate which will force
people to take their food more seriously
or know how to take their ramen right
you know cuz I hate that that concept of
like this is good enough I don't like
good enough I want it to be perfect in
the sense of what I find it to be
perfect I think with competition that
will happen yeah so I think what's
happening is the right now we're seeing
the bar and standards go up mm-hmm so
once mainstream America tastes like
Tatsuya or rekon or whatever or the
other one in uh West LA what's that one
that came from Japan food oh yeah like
once they taste that that becomes the
standard cuz they can't go back to like
the other ones that they've been going
to like what cons one of my favorite rom
is because they're so unique like their
ramen is uniquely theirs yeah right it
is and it's so [ __ ] good and he's
olive oil yeah maybe it's because that's
that's their fat that they have they
didn't it's [ __ ] delicious me I don't
use olive oil [ __ ] pork fat yeah I
use I like their style though but I
think so once the standard and the bar
goes up people will crave for that and
more and there's more people that are
going to Japan hella tourism that and
then when they come back they miss it
right and more Japanese people are
coming here to open up businesses it's
just gonna keep going up up and then
we're gonna start seeing some like
decent [ __ ] ramen places go outside
of LA New York yeah I can't wait man
even with the show you Robin that I make
I don't actually put men mine they're
like and then Maz like one of those if
bamboo shoots and that's like typically
what people want but when you get chewy
ramen you get that you
the eat the egg yeah I mean you get like
some anyway because when I when I put
them in mine there and I took it out I
didn't miss it
so I was like yeah I don't know it's an
old thing yeah like I think I eat it cuz
it's there and my grandma's scolding me
yes I
it wasn't there I wouldn't care for it
yeah I think like for men ma I like it
in the tonkotsu broth I don't know what
it does but I like that I don't know
that [ __ ] is that it has yeah but
because it already has like that that
fermented soy sauce to show you taste I
don't think I need Ben Ben MA and I
actually add more like top- green onions
in there cuz I want that fresh crunchy
bite with it yeah so I had a [ __ ] ton of
that and then you know piece of noted -
so that's the recipe that I like um that
when I make it and I think it's [ __ ]
delicious yeah would you open up a ramen
shop I think I would but it would be
open up two days a week though yeah like
I I would like I said the ramen shop
that I would have would be only Ching
Tung ramen only and then call that shop
lazy ramen yeah and I made another
recipe lacier of it the opposite with
Japanese people are I named another
recipe where it's she attack a mushroom
broth instead oh that that one I really
liked a lot to do you use fresh or do
you use the fresh dry oh I use fresh and
then the the tada that I make is based
off Ivan Orkin s recipe
oh because he actually does like a
sofrito so he'll take a bunch of chopped
vegetables like sheet like a shield tada
originally would just be like salt it
might be with like aromatics like garlic
and ginger and it'll be suck and that's
really about it in water but his has all
that but he cooks it cooks it with a
bunch of veggies and just melts it down
cause that as it's done it oh so I took
that but I did like a mushroom medley
with it and it tastes like that really
just just dank like it was just
vegetarian style yeah
but not really for me because the fat
that I use in it is coconut fat it's
coconut fat bacon fat and then olive oil
also the bacon is what I see so it has
like that salty like cured taste to it
damn that's cool man yeah yeah I want to
I just I don't want to commit to a
restaurant and cook there every day
helping if somebody else do it it's just
don't fall that's fine
yeah develop a menu that might be the
next career go is that what are you
doing for you didn't mention any of your
20/20 stuff
I think 20/20 what I really want to do
is so first I mean this is this is like
hobby stuff I am going to only cook
Korean and Japanese food
for the whole year for the whole year um
I mean that's doable
yeah like Japanese or Korean only for
one year yeah it's doable too because
there's so much on the menu I really
want to hone specific recipes down
because I'm bouncing around back and
forth too much then I'm becoming a jack
of all shits with my food
do you consider so when you say Japanese
are you doing only traditional or dude
is like Japanese Italian traditional
okay and then I'll put my own twist to
it if I want to because I want the
foundation like one thing that I'm
having the hardest time doing is [ __ ]
tempura frying it's just [ __ ] hard
man like yeah [ __ ] pissing me off
like it's it's decent you know I eat I'm
like oh it's decent I don't let it ride
that one Randa you're you're doing a
pretty crazy thing so like I'm gonna
hone down Japanese and Korean food to
the best dishes that I like typically
what I want to do is like when I say
masters what I'd like out of the food so
20 Japanese dishes 20 go to Korean
dishes that I that I know that I'm gonna
make that's a lot 40 dishes yeah and
then um so when I cook you can rotate 40
dishes for the whole year and that'll be
good yeah like that's a lot what what
I'd like to do when I cook is that um
uh-huh
this is like something that I don't
think I ever said this before when I
cook it I develop recipes for myself I
do it as if I developing an item that's
gonna go on a menu in a restaurant oh
yeah so that's why when I when I was
working on the the wing the wing chick
stresses yeah that was only like 10%
done literally the first few trials and
I you know I gave them the original
recipe and I allowed them to tweak it
the based on what people liked I only
did 10% of the work there but I reason
why I stopped because Merrythought tired
of eating chicken wings she told me no
more fried food she was gaining weight
oh and so I love chicken wings though
like I know it wasn't it wasn't done yet
so I I still haven't perfected it the
way that I want to and I still have
adjustments to make on it but I always
develop stuff based on if I were to
open up a restaurant when I put this on
my menu I see and if I'm not gonna put
it on my menu that means that I'm not
gonna cook that [ __ ] mmm that's why I
have I just cooked just to cook like I
just sometimes I have a goal mm-hmm
because I have a flavor in my mouth that
I want to achieve and other times I'm
like let's see what happens yeah you
know that's why I do like even when I
make American food I do like mac and
cheese and stuff like I eat it I'm like
I've always had better at a restaurant
so why the [ __ ] do I keep making this
[ __ ] yeah I think grow up on it that's
what I usually make things that I can't
get out of restaurant so I love cooking
steaks my way yeah I love cooking steaks
at home is way better do way better yeah
you know if you could get the same cut
of meat and you could cook it the way
that you want to why why even go there
just cheaper stay at home that's why do
it or you get inspired to go you know
what I want to make churros yeah or just
some funny thing to do you know oh I
just wish I had more time to do that
[ __ ] that's not a 2020 goal
unfortunately you know I've been telling
people to what a cool way to narrow down
your [ __ ] is because I am a
jack-of-all-trades and I just like
bouncing around because I love exploring
a lot right but the problem with that is
one you don't ever get to a certain
point and two you don't tell yourself
when is enough yeah so like I leave my
projects feeling like I didn't complete
anything hmm but if I made a commitment
to myself when I said hey I'm gonna stop
when I hit this then I could move to
something else yeah and so a good way is
I learned this online where you can
write down 25 things of what you want to
do and it can be anything like travel it
could be in what I what I typically do
is look for something that fulfills my
passion something that fulfills my
career and something that fulfills my
health those three things I try to
achieve so I don't have like five things
that's just on health or whatever right
yeah I need a balance so I grab 25 items
and then I take the five most things
that I want to complete like now and
what's most important to me and I take
the two the three top like passion
health career thing and
that becomes by three yeah so for the
hell thing I want to make I want to get
a six-pack so that's why all [ __ ] like
these Mel watch out
so everything okay everything outside of
that so like unfortunately i'ma have to
give up my karate for a minute I'm not
to give up like maybe MMA for a minute
or like maybe it would work but
generally the most effective thing to do
is diet and lifting yeah so that's all I
can really focus on because there's time
right so like and career things too like
I have some goals that I want to achieve
I can't really talk about it but yeah
and then for passion side I'm gonna
probably pick up music again so I'm kind
of interested in in that where this
stuff is untainted when it comes to
passion it's got to be a hobby or
something that you care about that
you're not thinking about making money
off of or anything and I think that
satisfies the soul no I think for me
like the goals that I have obviously
it's that food thing which is you know
something I really enjoy doing so I'll
be continuing that and obviously when I
eat healthier
most of these recipes have is gonna be
done on the weekends yeah they're in the
weekly I don't have time for that [ __ ]
oh yeah I'm [ __ ] impossible but other
than that I'm gonna lose the rest of the
weight that I want to lose what is your
goal how much you're trying to lose so
I'm like what to 15 to 17 right I lost
60 pounds yeah a certain point was 70
but then I gained almost 300 pounds I
was like 270 men what the [ __ ] egg bras
like a size 42 waist I didn't know that
I didn't know either man I was just
chilling right thought I was a sexy HT
[ __ ] out there dude
well sure I think we were all
collaborators um Bartley blew up at the
same time and we lost weight together
too and we're like girls on our periods
all synched up I know dude yeah so I
plan to lose like another 30 pounds um
get jacked and ripped I just want to do
it once just like a show my kids are
this is what it looked like and then
only show them that picture what is
jacked and ripped to you just um I mean
I don't need to be huge but like I would
like to just be a physical specimen once
in my life just so like I say that I did
it and afterwards I'll go back to just
being like
you know gotta flex in your pictures
every day exactly so I'm gonna finish
that up by the end of this year I want
to pick up a third language by the end
of this year as well I think I'm just
gonna go for Japanese I like I really
want to learn Spanish because of how
useful it is in LA but then Japanese I'm
ready like I'm like I understand so
[ __ ] much that I might as well just
learn how to speak it this yeah
cuz you'll you'll pick it up man cuz
when you're in Japan you hear is talk
you know the gist of the conversation
yeah you know you you you're gonna pick
it up like that yeah yeah cuz it's like
I said that go back to where I started
before and like Mario's like that too
she goes you understand everything that
I say in Japanese it's just you just
don't know how to put put the put
together sentences yeah so it's like
okay well since I'm already like you
know like 10% or 50% that I might as
well just finish up the rest
so probably learn how to speak Japanese
at like an elementary school level this
year and then after that I have like
personal finance goals that I want to
hit and then rebuild my wardrobe which
is the clothing thing oh yeah I want to
do that too because I have to throw I
lose like 30 pounds I'm gonna have to be
the way fashion yeah so rebuild that
wardrobe and then also learn how to
wrestle this year so I'm going oh hell
yeah I want to grapple this year so I
think jujitsu or wrestling uh wrestling
so grappling so I want to grapple and
then add jujitsu defense and everything
else after that so I'm gonna be working
on that and then cuz I kickboxing like
I'm not the best at it obviously but I'm
pretty decent at it now you got pretty
good though man yeah I mean I like from
when you first started to now like I
can't even touch you earlier oh beef
when I first started boxing with you I
was like oh my god you're so tall but I
could get right through yeah now I can't
even pass your [ __ ] arms I got really
obsessed with it so it's like well the
way you study is you're like me like we
get in and like you study but you go
further into like studying the fights
and all that stuff yeah so I like I
really develop that I want to develop my
my striking a little more but that's
hard to like if I want to develop my
fighting more am i striking I have to go
into a fight gym but I don't know if I
care enough to do that because it's a
fun for me they'll take the fun out of
it for me
and that's the important part is like
knowing
when you're okay with giving up certain
things in the pack before you pick up
something else yeah cuz I try to do
everything man
and even when I was approaching martial
arts I didn't focus on what I was doing
karate I was doing kickboxing I was
doing boxing I was doing you know and I
was all over the place and I'm like well
what am I doing this for am I trying to
murder somebody now it's really fun but
at the end of the day what I want I just
want to I just want to look good right
now yeah that's a good thing to say to
it's like when people lose weight ooh I
I think like the funniest thing that I
hear from a lot of people is that you
want to save the right answer for why
you want to lose no because you do not
want to be vain I've been fat for the
last five years that's what I like
though it's like some people I hear so
much [ __ ] because I know what they
want to say yeah I want to do this from
my I'm like you just want to look good
just say you want to look good I want to
look good man I'm 35 I don't have much
time man I'm gonna get I'm gonna get the
hard part done now so I could be the 55
year old like you know that food
Timberwolf that guy's hilarious man he's
55 ripped like a [ __ ] right I
mean he has the funniest captions he had
like this picture of him he's 16 years
old
and he's like ripped right and in the
caption he goes do you think your mom
would let me fist you in the 90s that's
so [ __ ] funny this was [ __ ]
hilarious dude what the [ __ ] yeah I mean
I would love to I mean when it comes to
fitness too and I want people to wrap
their head around this you can be ripped
and jak2 for your whole life but you
have to understand you have to live that
same lifestyle for the rest of your life
so yeah if if you like eating a lot of
great food yes there's like high fatty
food and you should be okay with having
a little fluff it's a give and take
that's just like yeah he's talking about
it to like guys his age he's like
they're they're wealthier they have all
the hills I've always been broke but
guess what I'm healthy and I'm still
banging 20 year olds and these guys
they're on multiple pills they're sick
they have money and I'm like damn dude
like that's really real what what do I
want I want both I want the body well
I'm you know well I'm still [ __ ]
dating and I'm [ __ ] like rich like
you know I want it all but I gotta be
realistic he's right
yeah you have one of the other I can't
have that body and being you know all
that but you know I guess it's it's it's
really a fitness guru you know you could
build like a fitness Empire I don't want
to be a fitness card yeah I don't care
about it as much either like I like I
care about healthy lifestyle but he
works out about three to four hours a
day I think he dedicates in a hot bath
[ __ ] he says and he he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's like yeah I'm broke but I'm
happy man hey if you're happy they hear
you you got it that's the goal that's
the goal it doesn't really matter man
that's why I always compare my life to
people in Hawaii that I see I'm like you
know they don't got much money but [ __ ]
look at how happy they are man we're
stressed yeah for what yeah for what
what's it what the [ __ ] the point I
don't know for I'm thinking morale
stressed people I'm naturally a
unstressed guy but I take on the
stresses of people around me that's why
this year I think your biggest goal is
that you're gonna focus on what you want
because your whole past five years have
you been developing stuff as a team and
for other people now you get to figure
okay well what does Joe want to do yeah
you know yes and it's it's it's exciting
and scary I'm a Nissan puss a 20 20 20
20 plus a 20 20 percent I will be
avoiding random [ __ ] for 2020 as I'm
doing I was staying home in [ __ ]
jackoff all day they're gonna be making
Korean and Japanese food you're getting
ready for husband skills yeah I am
preparing to be a good husband by eating
[ __ ] you're developing your husband's
skills with a future lady in the figure
8 shape is what they say the figure 8
shape did doing glowstick moves with my
tongue well guys this wraps up this
episode of eating [ __ ] for 2020 what
are your 2020 goals man what do you guys
wanna want to do for this year it's an
end of a decade so I'm kind of curious
to see what you guys plan to do leave it
in the comments below and if not just
speak about two other people and speak
your future into existence you [ __ ]
[ __ ] just like we're trying to do so
catch us on all those audio platforms if
you see us on iTunes give us that five
stars and we will see you guys next week
baby happy birthdays pace